[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier an administration under fire
tonight and at this hour there's no sign
that anyone's backing down the
president's pick for VA secretary dr.
Ronnie Jackson plans to stand firm
against allegations of improper conduct
and to press forward with his nomination
attorney general Jeff Sessions gets into
a testy exchange on Capitol Hill over
presidential pardons and the OMB
director and current head of the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
Mick Mulvaney pushes back hard on
newspaper reports about comments he made
in a speech this week about lobbyists
access to his congressional office it's
Wednesday
at the White House chief White House
correspondent John Roberts joins us from
the North Lawn with the latest
Big John good evening to you Brett and a
busy one it is today Democrats without
any evidence to back it up released a
laundry list of allegations and
accusations against dr. Ronnie Jackson
the man that the president wants to lead
the Veterans Affairs administration
among the allegations are accusations
that he mishandled opioid drugs and that
at a secret service party he got drunk
and wrecked a government vehicle after
meeting with the press secretary and
chief of staff late today dr. Ronnie
Jackson dismissed new democratic
allegations that he wrecked a government
vehicle after getting drunk at a secret
service party insisting it never
happened and that he is going to go
ahead with the confirmation process the
press secretary today saying none of the
allegations now raised about Jackson
were uncovered in successive background
checks dr. Jackson has had at least four
independent background investigations
conducted during his time at the White
House during each of those
investigations dr. Jackson received
unanimous praise from dozens of
witnesses and the investigations
revealed no areas of concern
Sara Sanders also noting that none of
the allegations were raised before
Jackson's nomination but the background
check should have picked up a medical
inspector general's report in 2012 that
found dr. Jackson exhibited poor
leadership in a dispute with a colleague
and as a result of the dispute overall
unit morale is at - on a scale of one to
two
one of Jackson's biggest detractors is
Montana Democratic senator Jon Tester
the ranking member of the VA committee
who insists Jackson has problems beyond
leadership as this doctor has a problem
because he hands out prescriptions like
candy in fact in the White House they
call him the Candy Man the word is is it
on overseas trips in particular that
Admiral would go down the aisle way of
the airplane and say all right who wants
to go to sleep and hand out the
prescriptions on overnight overseas
trips White House doctors do offer staff
even journalists aboard Air Force One
sleep aids I recommend that everyone on
the plane take a sleep aid at certain
times the Pentagon does the same on
trips with the Secretary of Defense but
the pills given out are recorded with
names and dosages testers candyman
comment drew a sharp response from the
White House legislative affairs director
oh it was absolutely unfair for me to
drop the can team in line I think that
there have been multiple every year they
come in and they do review of the White
House physician's office on things like
prescriptions and every year they've
said that that he's totally in
compliance with what he's been
prescribing this the White House
continues to push VA Committee Chairman
senator Johnny Isakson to reschedule
Jackson's confirmation hearing also on
Capitol Hill today Attorney General Jeff
Sessions under fire over reports his
recusal from the Russia investigation
does not extend to the investigation of
Michael Cohen are you accused from the
federal investigation of the president's
attorney Michael Cohen it is the policy
of the Department of Justice that those
who recuse themselves not a state the
the details of it and sessions got into
a heated exchange with Democratic
Senator Chris Van Hollen over
presidential pardons and whether they
went through the appropriate process did
the pardon of sheriff joseph arpaia go
through the part Attorney office I don't
believe it did did the pardon of Scooter
Libby go through they honest
and I don't believe it did I'm quoting
from a statement you made seen it was
abusive process in a particular case
made by the President Clinton I would
just say that pardons of President
Clinton made were stunning shocking and
unacceptable on the mayor and also
facing heat today the President's budget
director Mick Mulvaney over comments he
made yesterday in a speech to bankers
and payday lenders
speaking as the head of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau
Mulvaney told the group it was important
to make personal contact with their
member of Congress to get things done
Mulvaney's saying we had a hierarchy in
my office in Congress if you were a
lobbyist who never gave us money I
didn't talk to you if you were a
lobbyist who gave us money I might talk
to you if you came from back home and
sat in my lobby I talked to you without
exception regardless of the financial
contributions Democrats pounced on the
remarks slamming Mulvaney for promoting
pay-to-play in a statement Ohio senator
sherrod Brown ripping the kind of pay to
play that understandably makes Americans
furious with Washington DC mr. Mulvaney
should resign well-baby spokesman
insisted Fox News that his comments were
taken out of context that he was merely
praising the group for coming to
Washington DC and making the effort to
go knock on doors on Capitol Hill at a
development late this afternoon in the
Muller investigation sources tell Fox
News that Rudy Giuliani has taken over
negotiations with the special counsel
Robert Muller for a possible interview
with President Trump President Trump has
said he is that he has said in the past
that he's open to the idea but he's not
sold on it Rudy Giuliani passing that
message along to Robert Muller and just
to finish off Brett where we started
today the White House would like to see
dr. Ronnie Jackson get a hearing in the
Senate on his nomination but at this
moment tonight they don't know whether
he will stay in or whether he will leave
one official telling me if it was that /
if it was them they would get out Brett
John Roberts busy day again on the North
Lawn at the White House John thanks